L
HISTORY MUSEUM, AND I LOOKED AT
HOW THE PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN THEIR
ALL TO STAY STRONG, AND PROUD.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> PERHAPS THERE IS NO MORE
POWERFUL SENSE OF BELONGING
THAN THIS.
YOU ARENA, STARTING TO MARRY IN
THE ORTHODOX CHURCH, THE VERY
DAY RUSSIA INVADED AND TRIED TO
CLAIM THEIR NATIONAL IDENTITY.
INSTEAD OF A HONEYMOON, THEY
JOINED THE TERRITORIAL DEFENSE
AGAINST THE SIEGE OF THE
CAPITAL KYIV.
TODAY, LOOKING OVER THE YEAR OF
LIVING DANGEROUSLY, THE YOUNG
COUPLE TAKES STOP.
>> ONLY WHEN YOU SEE THIS, YOU
SEE THE VALUE OF LIFE AND IN MY
CASE, IT'S TOTALLY, 100%.
>> THIS WAR IS A TALE OF ETHNIC
RESISTANCE BY A WHOLE NATION,
AND THE CIVILIANS WHO BECAME
OVERNIGHT SOLDIERS.
>> THIS ONE YEAR OF THE WAR, IT
REALLY FEELS LIKE 40 YEARS OF
LIFE.
I DON'T FEEL MYSELF SO YOUNG
AGAIN, ANYMORE, JUST BECAUSE OF
THE EXPERIENCE, OF ALL THE
THINGS YOU HAVE SEEN.
>> THEY REMIND US JUST HOW MUCH
HAS BEEN LOST, EVERYONE HAS
FAMILY, FRIENDS, KILLED OR
WOUNDED.
WHEN UKRAINE BROKE THAT LONG
SIEGE AROUND KYIV, REVEALING
UNIMAGINABLE HORRORS, AND
CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY AND
BUCHA, IT'S DIFFERENT, NOT
SOFTENED PEOPLES RESISTANCE ON
THE RESOLVE.
ANY PEACE NEGOTIATIONS WOULD
NOW HAVE TO INCLUDE
PROSECUTIONS, AND JUSTICE.
AND AN END TO ANY RUSSIAN
CLAIMS ON THE TERRITORY, OR
THEIR IDENTITY.
WHEN WE VISITED THE
NEWLY-LIBERATED SUBURB OF
BORODYANKA LAST APRIL, EVEN
MONUMENTS TO UKRAINIAN ART, AND
LITERATURE WEREN'T SPARED.
WE WITNESSED THE DELIBERATE A
SALT ON OTHER CULTURAL
HERITAGE.
SO THIS IS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
IDEA OF LIBERATING A FRATERNAL
BROTHERLY NATION.
SO EITHER HE'S DOING ALL THIS
BECAUSE HE LOVES UKRAINIANS, OR
AS MANY BELIEVE, BECAUSE HE'S
MOTIVATED BY A RISING HATRED,
AND ANGER AT THEIR WESTWOOD
LOVING DEMOCRACY, AT THE
RESISTANCE, AND AT THE REFUSAL
TO COME UNDER RUSSIAN CONTROL.
FROM KHARKIV, TO KHERSON,
ODESSA, TO DONBAS, MUSEUMS,
OPERA HOUSES, AND ART HAVE BEEN
TARGETED, LOOTED, AND
DESTROYED.
AND HE HAD, A HEROIC EFFORT TO
SAVE AND PROTECT THIS HERITAGE
HAS BEEN UNDERWAY SINCE THE
FIRST MISSILE STRUCK.
HERE, AT THE NATIONAL MUSEUM OF
THE HISTORY OF UKRAINE, AN
EXHIBIT ON THIS PAST YEAR OF
WAR, AND ESPECIALLY REMINDERS
THAT SO MANY RUSSIAN TARGETS
WERE CLEARLY MARKED, CHILDREN,
PEOPLE LIVE HERE.
FORMER DEPUTY CULTURAL MINISTER,
ALESSIO OSTROWSKI LUTA TELLS US
THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY, MANY
CURATORS TOOK SHELTER INSIDE,
WITH OTHER COLLECTIONS.
>> THAT'S THE SITUATION A
VIRTUALLY OF UKRAINIAN MUSEUM.
YOU CAN'T HAVE OBJECTS FROM THE
COLLECTION, MUSEUM OBJECTS ON
THIS, BUT THEY HAVE TO BE
SECURED, THEY HAVE TO BE CARED
FOR.
>> THE INSTALLATION HANGING IN
THIS TERRIBLE REMINDS US OF THE
WAR ACTUALLY BEGAN IN 2014,
WITH PUTIN'S ANNEXATION OF
CRIMEA, INCLUSION OF DONBAS,
AND AN ATTEMPT TO CRUSH AN
INDEPENDENT NATION, CALLING
THIS RISKY MERE, GREATER
RUSSIA.
ALESSIO CALLS THAT ABSURD.
>> I DON'T THINK THIS IS
UKRAINIAN IDENTITY.
THERE IS A PROBLEM --
IT'S RUSSIA'S IDENTITY.
IF RUSSIAN IDENTITY IS IMPERIAL,
UKRAINE IS ESSENTIAL PART OF IT.
BUT, IF YOU WOULD THINK RUSSIAN
IDENTITY AS A NON IMPERIAL
IDENTITY, THEN YOU DO NOT NEED
UKRAINE, POLAND, BALTIC STATES
WITHIN A ROME.
>> THAT OF COURSE IS THE POINT
OF PUTIN'S WAR, TO CRUSH THIS
DEMOCRACY, WHO IS NOW WORLD
FAMOUS FLAG WAS FIRST PUBLICLY
RAISED IN 1990, JUST AHEAD OF
INDEPENDENTS.
BEFORE THAT, THE SOVIETS
WOULD'VE JAILED ANYONE CAUGHT
CARRYING IT.
TODAY, ALESSIO SAYS IT REMAINS
A SYMBOL OF COURAGE, RESISTANCE,
AND STATEHOOD.
>> NOBODY, A YEAR AGO THOUGHT
THAT THIS COUNTRY WOULD STILL
BE STANDING.
I MEAN, WE THOUGHT THAT THAT
FLAG WOULD NOT EXIST ANYMORE.
THAT THIS WOULD BE RUSSIA
AGAIN.
>> WE DIDN'T THINK THAT, AT
ALL.
AT ALL.
I REMEMBER --
LIKE >> UKRAINIANS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY, NEWLYWEDS, YOU ARENA
AND SVYATOSLAV WILL MARK THIS